everything's fine ah uh
this is gonna be really rough
hey guys it's katie and i'm back today
with my good friend from buzzfeed india
etiquette since you guys asked for it i
am here back with katie to teach her
another indian recipe and this time it's
a dessert or ajbi myself hindi maybach
and at the end of it we'll compare the
real dish with whatever katie ended up
with and see how well she did katie are
you excited i am excited i haven't been
studying i should have like brushed up
or like re-watched the video since we've
done this before this time you're only
going to get one lifeline which is the
google it so you can google a phrase or
sentence which i say and it'll tell you
exactly what to do that's your only
lifeline so use it wisely i feel like
i'm going to like i've graduated from
like first graders kindergarten it's
good and a little harder i do remember
the numbers though a doe
team char
ponch that's great but this time i feel
like we are going to work a lot with
fractions which you don't know anything
about
but i am super excited because this is
one of my favorite desserts ever well i
guess let's just get started because
there's no turning back now hello
[Music]
you've sent me all the ingredients i
like the rose water and the pistachios
i'm excited i really have no idea what
we're making okay
so
[Music]
all right so team over char
cup
one cup flour aadhaa otta is half a cup
sugar oil ghee butter mate also is half
a cup flour
half
baking powder oh you guys sell baking
powder baking powder yeah it's it's
english chocolate is a little bit so i'm
getting like a half a teaspoon
chota baking powder absorption
yeah like dude what would we do
[Laughter]
[Music]
make it a ball cover it and put it off
to the side
wow wow
wow um okay so it needs to be in the
ball
no earthly clue what we're making we're
going to set it aside
[Music]
sugar ha that sounds cute and makes
sense
honey i think is water yes so we're
making some type of syrup i'm assuming
some type of sugary hahaha
yeah
[Music]
smells so delicious so two eliach
quesa is that saffron ha
i'm gonna guess a couple strands huh
this stuff is expensive so expensive
char or do you think like punch
let's live a little
let's go crazy wild with the saffron
face
bring it to a boil
that is the best thing that anyone has
ever done so turn up the heat
keep going stir the whole time
stir the sugar till it's dissolved
wow katie did you take hindi classes
while i was away all i heard was chidi
and i remember like chinese sugar
and i'm strange we're almost there we're
almost there
five minutes to boiling yeah so we
should just hang out there don't catch
up
[Laughter]
so right now we're just like
yeah we don't have the ing but it just
makes it funnier
oh what is that boil
obalo okay got it well we
lemon juice
[Music]
i'm like on another planet i have been
obsessed with rose water is rose water
gulab jab
yes
so that's a tablespoon
oh this smells delicious
[Music]
foreign
is it okay that it kind of has bumps on
here
no
i ended up rolling the whole thing i
think some of them are have cracks but
you're not gonna like they probably
won't make the cut this sounds like
american idol
they're not gonna make the cuts
like cutting do i google it now carlo
use lifeline i feel like you're gonna
regret this but sure
okay
so i think i'm just going to fill this
up to like where it would cover the ball
i'm assuming we're frying the balls ah
thermometer
yes
ah you put a little otta
okay to see when it's you don't know the
time
no
i wish you could be here so you can see
if the color
is right or not i think this guy looks
good
they look okay so i think they're pretty
cool now abu gholilo or chashni medal
though you told me this before chashni
trash nate what's sugar again genie oh
cha yes chashni chashni trashni shashni
yes chashni okay i have it
so they're going to soak in this
oh my goodness
it smells like roses it smells so good
okay so we're going to let these chill
hang out
pistachio
cashew cashew cajun
[Music]
pizza
[Music]
a plate a bowl
i've got the bowl
they're so beautiful
put more syrup on it
this is indulgent
oh my god
[Music]
oh it's so pretty
are we done we are done we did it
i'm so happy and so amazed at how well
you picked everything up and you did it
thank you so much i want to see what
yours looks like i am so excited to show
you what i have and and taste test it
together i'm nervous i want to see if
they're closed
[Music]
do you have any idea what this might be
no it looks familiar to me like i
definitely think i've seen it before but
i've definitely never eaten it before
okay it is gulab jamun i thought gulab
jamun
was
the like
batter that is i think that's jalebi
jalebi that's what i've had before so
gulab means rose and the chashni is made
of rose water and jamun is actually a
fruit in india i think it's called a
black plum in english so this kind of
looks like a fruit that's why they just
call it jamun but it's not i mean of
course it doesn't have any relation to
the actual fruit itself is this like one
of your favorite desserts i mean it
seems really popular i've definitely
heard the name before it is definitely
popular uh in in the northern side of
india uh my mom used to make this a lot
when i was growing up so
um this is very like special to me also
come on yours are huge yeah they've been
sitting in the syrup for so long they've
just become so huge so they just grow
they will grow like you give it some
time they will they should like double
up in size oh my god okay you know what
i already can see that i put one on the
top and it's tiny but the ones below it
are already like swelling soaking up
let's try this
it's crunchy it's sweet it's refreshing
but that chashni is like so refreshing
with the rose water in the saffron i
want this all the time this was so much
fun thank you so much i feel like i
learned even more about hindi today i
had such a good time with you same i had
such a good time it's always so much fun
to
introduce you to desserts and food i eat
here all the time you guys should go
definitely check out buzzfeed india
there's more videos in anakin and all
his friends it's super fun and let us
know in the comments if there's any
other challenges or things you want us
to try together because we just want to
keep hanging out we totally want to keep
hanging out so let us know what i should
teach katie next alright we'll see you
later bye katie bye bye guys
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you